so one of the things that i've mentioned
many times
is that if we understand christ as being
as the top of the hierarchy
we get a good glimpse of what he is
doing but we don't get all of it we need
to understand
christ as filling up the entire
structure
symbolic structure you could say filling
up the hierarchy of reality
and so i wanted to look at the
beatitudes specifically the beatitudes
in the book of matthew
and show you structurally what is going
on of course i'm not going to
go into all the details of the attitudes
and i'm actually not going to look at it
in terms of ethical and ethical question
or a moral question
but we're going to look at them
structurally and see how they kind of
manifest
the symbolic world that we've been
talking about for all this time
so just like a good movie the beatitudes
that's presented in matthew
you really get the beginning of the
beatitudes at the beginning of this of
the text
is what will set up a little microcosm
which will help you understand
everything else that is going on in the
text and so
in the first statement we will see let's
say there will be a layout of the
structure and then the rest of the text
will flow from that layout
and so it starts of course in matthew 5
and
i'm reading from the king james version
but in this case it doesn't really
matter which version you're reading from
because we're looking we're not looking
at a subtle theological
detail let's say and so talking about
christ it says
in matthew 5 and seeing the multitudes
he went up into a mountain
and when he was set his disciples came
unto him
so basically if you understand the
beatitudes it's all right
there uh for the first thing that we see
is he sees the multitudes okay and so
you have this
mass that's a mass of people this group
of
of people that are not really a group
they're
the multitudes they're the mixed
multitudes they're they're kind of
frenetic
uh multiplicity that's what he's seeing
and so he sees it
that's the problem let's say i've always
talked about how
reality always manifests itself as
a problem and answer and so this is what
he sees he sees this
this multitude and so he goes up into a
mountain
then it says when he was set i think it
means that when he sits down so he sits
down on the
imagine it in your mind you know imagine
like a really nice mountain and then
christ sits down at the top of the
mountain
and all of a sudden he's at the top of
reality and
he and his disciples come unto him and
so they gather around him
and so now we have already have the
difference between the multitude
and though the disciples that gather
around him as he is now at the top
of the mountain standing at the top of
reality and it's from this
point from the top of reality like the
law coming down from heaven
that he opens his mouth and now he
speaks
and so what christ is going to say is
going
to manifest this mystery the mystery of
how christ
being at the top of the mountain but
also going down all the way down to the
bottom of the mountain or you can
understand
that his teaching goes all the way down
to the bottom of the mountain
like pentecost which goes all the way to
the edge of the earth
you know like him descending into death
at the crucifixion
uh you you get a sense in which
he goes down and gets the fish at the
bottom of the water
you know the light shines in the
darkness and so in in here you'll see
that there's an aspect of the darkness
that doesn't know him
but there is an aspect of the darkness
which recognizes him there's an aspect
of the darkness of the little fish that
are shining in the water
which will recognize the light coming
from above okay
and so this is what he's going to say
he's going to say what is it at the
bottom
all this multitude is there at the
bottom and i am the divine logos at the
top of the mountain
and so as i speak i'm going to tell you
how what is it at the bottom which can
receive or which will recognize or which
will
receive the light and will recognize the
light and so
this is what the beatitudes are about
and they can help you understand
how reality is connected together okay
and so you'll see how
in the the text he moves from the top to
the bottom and how he
shows the connection between the top and
the bottom okay and so he says
blessed are the poor in spirit for their
for the for theirs is the kingdom of
heaven now
right now you can see what he's doing
he's saying those that are poor
in spirit those that are
low down on the hierarchy of materiality
you know but are poor in the spirit
that's a good way of understanding it
there are obviously other interpretation
but in this
this case is to say that you're poor but
you're in you're in the spirit you're
down there at the bottom of
let's say uh this kind of material
reality but you're but you have
you're in you're in the spirit being
down there
then the kingdom of heaven is yours
because that's where you are
you're at the bottom of the mountain and
so you're not you receive the kingdom of
heaven
and you manifest the kingdom of heaven
and so you could say it that
if we go back to the first verse he's
saying something like
those that are poor in spirit out of the
multitudes they're the ones who will be
those disciples
that come unto me those will be the ones
that will be gathered together
and become a kingdom which is united by
the light by the
the logos which is coming out coming
from above
um and so then he continues and he keeps
showing things that are down there below
of the hierarchy and he he connects them
he shows
how they can be connected to the top and
so he says blessed are they that mourn
for they shall be comforted and you have
to imagine
understand the comforting coming from
above once again the comforting is akin
to
the blessing is the king to this kingdom
of heaven which is which is coming down
to those who are weeping below
and you can understand it that they're
mourning out of
out of compassion they're mourning out
of love of others and so
that's what morning is it so the idea
that if you mourn
and you are if you are sad for others
then you will receive the kingdom of
heaven you will be comforted
that is how we are gathered together
once again that's how we become a
kingdom
if we mourn for one another and so again
blessed are the meek
the meek is the same thing blessed are
those that have
the capacity to act but don't act
against others that have
let's say the the power because they're
at the bottom they have this
they have this power but they don't use
it against
their neighbor then they are the ones
who will
become a kingdom they are the ones who
will join together into into uh
into a unity um and so again now you
have this the image of
being hungry so being poor being sad
being hungry all these things that are
negative in the sense that
they usually represent someone that is
below the hierarchy but he's saying
those that are hunger that are hungry
and thirsty
but that are hungry and thirsty after
righteousness well they shall be filled
they will receive from above
righteousness
righteousness will come down from above
for them
blessed are those that are merciful for
they shall obtain mercy again
mercy mourning all of these things you
know
meekness and they're all related you can
understand how being merciful to your
neighbor and being meek in the sense of
not acting
against him these are the ways in which
you know if we forgive each other
these are the ways in which we will
cohere if we don't forgive each other if
we hold things against
the those around us then we will become
the multitudes that he talked that we
see at the beginning
we will just be a bunch of points that
aren't connected together in love
and so we will not be able to cohere as
a world
and so he continues blessed are the pure
in heart for they shall see god
so this is a very powerful image this is
really like a cosmic image you can
understand
the heart as this point which is in the
mountain or below the mountain
you know imagine now the image of the
birth of christ where
he is this small child which is in the
manger he's in the heart of the mountain
and so
those that are pure in their heart those
that are
that so think you have to understand
he's showing things that you can imagine
are
normally seen as negative in the sense
not pure and hard but in the sense of
he's saying basically if you don't have
if your heart is not attached to things
if your heart is not attached to the
things that are down below there
then it will be available to receive the
light from above
and so don't be attached to the things
that are next to you
you will receive the light from above
and of course
related to all those other things if we
all do that then
and we all do the other things that he's
saying then we will also cohere we'll
become a body rather than a multitude
blessed are the peacemakers for they
shall be called children of god
obviously now all of these just
hopefully i don't even have to explain
them to you that all of this makes sense
right if you make peace you'll become a
child of god but
see how he's always showing this hot
above and below
he's always saying if you are in a
certain way at the bottom of the
of reality it will actually make you
receive from
above the the light the word and will
help you cohere and become
a body um and this is of course
blessed are they that are persecuted for
the sake of righteousness
for theirs is the kingdom of god and so
this one is
tougher it's harder to understand
but you have to understand it in
relationship to the image of the pure
heart let's say
that is if you look up
and you see righteousness coming from
below you see the light coming from
below
right and you you're attached to truth
you're attached to the good
you're attached to all these things and
then there are those
that around you that aren't those people
will not be happy with you because
they they will notice the difference
between you
and them and the way that they're acting
in the world and so therefore they will
tend to hate you
and of course when it says this it's
related to this image
or in the gospel of john where it talks
about how the light comes into the world
but the world does not know and
the world there's a there's a negative
world let's say the fallen world
this world that is all out for
themselves that is
that is breaking apart that is that is
tyranny and uh chaos like these two
excesses
that world will not accept those that
receive righteousness
that receive righteousness from above
and
are able to act in accordance with that
righteousness those that participate in
the kingdom of heaven
will find enemies in those that want
those extremes that want
either the kind of extreme of tyranny or
this extreme of chaos
um and those people will persecute you
and that that will happen especially
uh especially in this moment before the
body was
was if before the body was strong let's
say in the church
um but it's still even in the church it
continues like the church always has
this aspect of the world which
it can't com sadly can't completely get
rid of but hopefully it is kind of
exercising in time
um and so again the same you know
blessed
are blessed are you when men hate you
when they persecute you and they say
evil things against you falsely
for my sake and this is of course again
they
they this is not just that men hate you
and persecute you
of course this is not what it's saying
it's that the hatred persecute
persecute you for the sake of your
attachment to heaven
of your attachment to the divine logos
of your attachment to truth
of your attachment to light and when
mate hate when men hate you because of
that
then you you should rejoice
right you should rejoice and be
exceedingly glad
because your reward is in heaven right
your reward comes from above it doesn't
come
from uh receiving the glory of that
which is
at the level where you are it comes from
above
and but but ultimately that reward which
comes from above
will also look like a communion of love
will look like the disciples that come
unto him
that christ mentioned at the beginning
of the text
and so it was just i just wanted you to
be able to see
how the all the attitudes are about
showing
how christ fills the hierarchy from all
the way to the top and all the way to
the bottom and shows us
how it is in the aspect of ourselves in
ourselves how
we can being below god right being below
him
how we can be the way that we can become
the type of potential that is able to
become a body
right so the type of potential that is
not the kind of
angry chaos or the the the bitter waters
that are the you know that are incapable
of
participating in life but that the
bitter water this is how
you could say the miracle in the desert
where the bitter waters become the sweet
waters by the cross it's like christ is
telling us
this is how you become the sweet waters
this is how you become
the productive waters those that can be
used to
to bring life into the world and and
those that can be used
so how can you be a body that is
coherent and
functions together now it's really
important to understand that
we also have to understand that the this
teaching of the beatitudes
is not the totality of christ's teaching
and so we have to be careful because
there is a way in which we also
then fractally will play the role
that christ is playing towards us and
this
is you can understand the rest of some
of the things
that christ is saying um
as saying okay so this is how it works
right for here's how the top
relates to the bottom this is how heaven
is an image of that which gives which
gives blessing
which gives coherence which gives you
know the possibility of the body to come
together
which separates you from the evil and
from the the chaotic
waters of the world and now you have to
play
that role as well into the world so it's
showing you the positive
aspect of hierarchy and how hierarchy
works properly
so that's why right after the the
beatitudes
christ says things like you are the salt
of the earth you are the light of the
world a city
set on a hill cannot be hid so now he's
putting you at the top he's saying
you are the light of the world you are
that you are also like me
if you do these things if you become
this image
of that which is below and coheres
together under god and becomes
a body then you will fractally
become little christ and you will become
the light
of the world and you will have and you
will create this light
you will also participate in this light
which goes down into the darkness
and coheres darkness into bodies and so
that's why all the images after that are
about you are the light now
so you you know it talks about
you light a candle you don't if you
light a candle you don't hide it but you
put it up on a candlestick
and then it gives light onto the house
so this image of
light at the top of the candle which now
lights up this space lights up the house
is the same image of christ sitting
at the top of the mountain seeing the
multitudes and speaking so that his
disciples come unto him and cohere
around him
as a body and so i mean i could keep
going and show you the
the show you the the different aspects
but i just wanted you to show
help you see first of all how the
beatitudes are this
showing of how christ fills up the
hierarchy then also how the part which
comes right after
is there to fractally manifest how if
you
if you become this if you if you lower
yourself in relationship to christ if
you
break down your attachments to all the
chaotic things and you rather
look up then you will be the type of
person which will cohere into a body
and then in that body you will fractally
act
the way that christ is acting unto us
and so
the hierarchy will repeat itself at all
the different levels of
of reality and that is basically that's
how the world exists that's how the
world holds together
and so of course there would be much
more to say about the beatitudes than
that
but i was hoping that this little uh
this kind of little meditation and
beatitudes
can help you continue to read the
gospels and read the scripture
and see how it is completely coherent
with the narrative
right from the beginning of genesis and
all the narratives that kind of show
this
this embodied this symbolic structure
christ is also doing that in a way in a
very surprising way
in a way that heals the world that saves
the world that shows us how
the world can cohere and come together
in love and so
um so i hope this was useful to you
thank you for your attention i know a
lot of you are waiting for my video
on the mark of the beast i would just
tell you to be patient on that
because i i there are still a few things
that i
i need to understand and i need to get
right before
i talk about this because it is tricky
it is because it's dealing with
contemporary phenomenons dealing with
kind of political situations and i
definitely don't want to
misspeak and say something irresponsible
and so uh so so be patient will be worth
your weight
so thank you for your attention
everybody and i will talk to you very
soon